[Music]
so
right now you're going
their like is sinking
tilt them by tilting their arms
do you see that i feel that
feel this difference first push
every time
in your center
okay
so your
center gets
okay so watch your center in this other
version you're doing watch your center
is it doing anything
no okay
so
it doesn't matter where you are
okay all right so
watch first tristan
so i'm going to do the same thing
always
um
the first thing you have to know is what
it's not
okay you have to
it's not this
you see
it's something else
you have to know what it's not
so that you go on the hunt
okay
most people
will not hunt
they just stay with that first thing
okay
um
then they pretend that they saw
something else so they they think that
that was what they were looking at
but you can see
it's different
okay
so i want you to look at what happens to
his center
not how he falls or whatever
what is happening to his center
okay this whole pelvis area
okay so i'll do the
same drills before
okay
now
you go well that looks different
okay
and you have only
two
possible answers
one
he he's faking it
he's he's
but if you understood motion his body
can't go that way
okay uh or two
it's something
i don't yet understand
so then you keep hunting
okay
you have to first start there
i don't understand it but it's different
okay
don't let the fact that you don't
understand it
justify you not hunting
okay
all right let's try it again
let me use your
right
okay
uh
one of the common
i told you where
i told you what your aim was
your aim is the pelvis region okay
um
but people will hear that and then
they're going to do skeletal alignment
into the shoulders
do you understand this so uh let's say
we're here and the skeletal alignment
do you see that and you're doing that
all kinds of ways okay that's in her
shoulders right
and i'm i want this thing to
that thing you see do you see that okay
shoulders
eventually you'll tip that over that's
really no different than this
in terms of
the angle of disturbance okay uh
wherever even if you're in here that
thing has to go into her body whole into
her body okay
uh
so you're you're wherever you're
touching we're trying to displace the
center do you see
however you touch yeah and then in
in
okay
then you can stay holding on unless i
project you okay oh because i want to
show you
back off you see
in the body
in the body back off you feel that
there it is
and it's not a matter of going low
because you can go high you see look at
her pelvis whoa do you see how she's
going like that oh not it's in her
shoulders it tips up
whoa
there
you see i'm changing the angles of her
pelvis okay
okay
so again i don't know
how it's happening
i don't understand
but it's not the other thing
okay
uh so you have to hunt
all right so what is it not it's not
skeletal alignment in the shoulders
that is a throw you can throw them like
that but same as the other one the other
one's the throw you can tell people but
it's not the skill we're working on
right now okay
so uh
you can see
uh
wherever
and the reason i went to this side you
see
i i he was grabbing me in the in the
drills and then i went to this side on
rain did you go notice that i stopped
her grabbing me and i stuck to her
you see you get it and that that's again
you're like what
okay because now obviously
it's not me going into his shoulders
because i
can't
i'm here okay and that's enough
you see
okay
so again i don't know what it is
cool
keep going keep hunting
okay
all right so i'm not trying to lock your
shoulders and push your shoulders that's
not it okay
there you go
and
we're gonna look at
what was said that there's a this
pivoting
this the center is pivoting
okay
okay does everyone sing the pivoting
and the other uh
alternative
was
uh projecting
so can you define the difference between
projecting and pivoting and we're
talking about the center right and we're
talking about this to uh
note the difference so that i can begin
to hunt because if it's not different if
it is what i'm doing there's no hunt
okay
so
what how would you define
a pivoting of the center versus a
projecting of the center
anyone go for it
requires so when she comes in
uh it requires a hard surface where his
center actually stops moving for a split
stick and then she's able to pivot off
that center incense versus projecting
which is the center comes in it's still
moving and it comes back out and it's
always moving okay how about we use
dimensions here
so pivoting
you're only moving
in one plane or in two dimensions
whereas with the projection you're
getting all three dimensions of movement
yeah and in particular the sagittal
plane
do you get that if if it's not
traversing the sagittal plane it's not
projecting okay so
uh
if i if i have a center and i have this
vertical plane here
and i am just
tilting it
in that plane do you see
but if i
start moving it do you see
it's not just tilting it
but
it gets
traversing in the sagittal plane do you
see that so i want you to be if you're
going to hunt
you have to be specific you have to
define these things okay
uh if you see something different
hunting means try to find out what is
different
okay
so
uh
pivoting
right there's nothing wrong with
pivoting there's nothing you you can't
pivot by the same means you see but our
drill is doing something different with
those beans okay so i'm not doing at
home
this way i'm doing this
do you see that okay
um
and this is gonna tie us back to your
your original question okay
if you pay attention
right
uh
nothing is happening to him nothing is
happening to him nothing is happening to
him nothing is happening to him and now
something's happening too
okay
but he's here
and something was happening to him
before my arms went back out dc but it's
so smooth and fast
that it looks like
uh nothing's happening to him nothing's
happening to it nothing's happening to
him nothing until i start to go out
but something was happening to him when
i came back
and that's that's what that's what you
noted it was like the the percussion the
percussiveness is not there because
nothing's happening to you nothing's
happening to you until you go here you
see
okay
and really if you now look closer i'll
take my original uke
so you can see
my arms are not
uh although they go in and out of my
body like away and in and out of my body
to some degree
uh he was already going that way
do you unders
you gotta look for it now okay
it's not me going here
you get that he's already
do you see
and so
it's it's very subtle why do my arms go
out with him because i'm keeping
that
connection
you see
this is training
that's all but i'm not pushing him it's
not a violation of yin and yang
okay he's going that way and i'm going
with him that way okay so as i'm doing
it
boom there's already a re-per a
percussive energy that way okay you have
to make sure
that he hits
that
okay
and then you're just following it
you know i just take away
this little beat there i'll just smooth
it out
so it looks
like
in out
in
out
but
it it did not really look like that
you just thought you understood it
he's actually going
out do you see
i'm going i'm going this way he ends up
going the other way
boom do you think it's not that he's
here
until i go there okay so we're here
and i'm going to do the same hand
positioning
but
traverse
okay
so it's something else
keep hunting
[Music]
okay um
what was his understanding
yeah the person is going up and out that
way
so i must go up and out that way
you see that oh that must be it okay
uh
so now you have first you gotta go was
that what i was watching right so if i
go
and i'm going up
am i going up like this
or
okay
so now go
uh
which way is he going
it's not a
okay that's how you hunt
it's not up which way is he going
can you tell
down down
do you see down this is the opposite
okay it's the opposite okay
so this way made sense to where you're
at now
how do i go the other way
and make them go the other way okay you
get well that's
you gotta hunt for it okay
uh but we know that energy all the time
it's rebounding energy
do you get it you wanna bounce the ball
up you gotta first throw it down and
it'll bounce up off of it it's very
similar okay
all right
let's try it
so um
the point you were making was that you
you could feel you could feel closer to
it if you remain relaxed okay
um
and the
response i made was i think uh
tension
uh blocks
that with his energy
or stops or
causes it to deflect away from the
greater mass
here the earth
and inhibits the rebounding okay
uh so example of this is if he's pushing
and i tense it stays up in my shoulders
do you see and you can see my stance
lift you see
but the more i relaxed i am it goes down
it goes down into my body okay
uh that tension can happen anywhere it
could happen down on my legs even you
see uh it's
not quite all the way in okay
uh so i have to be very relaxed
very relaxed and that's now that's
really weird because um
in the same way that this was
somewhat
intuitive right
um
this is what we imagined by relaxing
but that's all that's obviously uh not
not what's happening do you see
uh do you get that and so but this isn't
it either
that's not it either okay that's the
kind of energy yes and energy and yeah i
can aim it into his center and yeah i
can traverse his center along the mat
but that was not what i saw do you see
the arms are very loose the face
everything is very very loose do you get
that okay
um but it was it wasn't that either
okay
um
let us
we'll do a few so you could you could
watch
[Music]
okay um
something totally is different okay so
you have to stop looking there and you
have to keep hunting
okay
um
in my opinion all of the
understandings can only be metaphorical
okay
they're they're
they're
literary they're language games you see
so if i talk about
uh
the energy being blocked into my
shoulders
it's metaphorical if i say the cheek is
blocked it's metaphorical to me
and and what most of all keeps it
metaphorical is that even if i have the
description the literary description i
won't be able to do it okay
so uh that's why i just go with it's not
that keep hunting it's not that keep
hunting it's not that keep hunting so so
far
um we have had
uh that it's not it's it it's in his
center it's in his center
it's not in his shoulders do you see
we also had it the first one was we're
not tilting him and you could tilt him
with good things obviously this was a
beginner technique right i mean
this is still tilting him
that's still tilted here um we also had
that uh
his center is projected not just
spinning in one plane his center is
moving traversing do you see uh the
sagittal plane
and it was also that his phone going
back before my arms go out okay
uh
and then we had the one that my center
is going down my center is not going up
to make him go up and now we have this
one it is very relaxed okay it's very
relaxed so uh these are all like um
you know
what 120 miles to disneyland yeah keep
going you're not there yet right 75
miles and keep going you're not there
yet okay just use these as signposts
okay